e se all'inizio del video rotolo
joystick vuol dire che sarà un bel vl a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono falli già oggi siamo su super
football gioco di calcio ma ma figo
proprio pound
non ho ben capito la madonna come
funziona sta roba per cosa vi serve il
giovane doveva è va bene allora io ti
odio con tutto l'amore del mondo
non ho cosa state facendo non si giochi
a calcio cosa come giochi tua calcio non
lo prende più nessuno e tangenziale non
sia ora che partitico aiuto cosa stanno
facendo
ma cos'è quella roba lì va beh uno
contro uno ok 1 contro 1 1 1 proprio
così gli fa una quarto perfetto dove
cazzo stanno dove andare dove perché
perché arbitro faccia qualcosa
io sono l'arbitro in play uno solo che
sono io a questo posso giocare bene
posso giocare io da solo perfetto si può
calciare no devi usare i calci non così
devi calciare la palla svegliati
svegliati zio no busi ha gentilmente
voglia di spiegarmi cosa servono cos'è
santo di dio allora fermi voglio provare
a calciare una volta il pallone una
volta non ti chiedo di fare che io
calcio a una volta ok va bene no no
perché ero riesci quanti problemi perché
c'è vabbè ok controlla il pallone posso
calciarlo giusto bene perfetto adesso vi
mettete in posizione non è quella la
posizione di meno
vi mettete un po no dove deve arrivare
gli avversari che cazzo fate la prendo
io la palla sono io l'arbitro moduli
crono fermi fermi cosa vuoi vai via vai
via
un fenomeno volo sucate brema per
l'iphone
ogni tanto sono riuscito a portarmi la
palla dietro non so come ma gli altri
blu sono morti sono cosa state facendo
voi tutti scemi nella madonna per fare
anche le bolle più grosse la boyle
grossa lable crossa e più grossa
parliamo la gente piano piano piano lo
ammazzo tutti mamma deve cercare di
segnare o di far divertire la gente il
pubblico nel cercare di iniziare la
partita quello il problema
la palla è mia pieni qua non store
dovunque laurent cos'è fermi d'oliva ci
sono delle macchine che cazzo e rocket
league si può andare in macchina così a
caso gta è diventato no è bravi bravi
bravi entrate entrate perfetto dentro
dentro dentro il campo ragazzi dentro
non ce la fate vabbè se per caso la
palla riuscissi a prenderla l'app di
porto tutti i deboli di un perfetto vai
vai vai vai attacca cosa vai via
passano anche gli autobus qui dentro
entrata perfetto per sé o quello che
allora adesso si gioca la palla e quella
perché c'è un incastrato nel palo perché
c'è una rampa hanno capito aicarr sei
serio per caso anche la macchina va
contro la palla perché in quel caso
potrebbe essere un problema ragazzi
toglietevi la strada ragazzi ragazzi
ragazze allora calmi calmi
facciamo 5 x 35 x 3 facile 15 spagnoli
15 moon spam
ok non vuol dire che se salto salto è la
madonna quanto salta barbara troppo
quali scenderanno non c'è proprio la che
giustamente sulla luna non è che cazzo
non è esattamente la situazione che mi
aspettavo ragazzi prova quanto belli per
oggi da dove è uscito bello tutto bene
frate leggero eco invita snella tu
volevi solo una giornata normale zio lo
so ti capisco no lì in mezzo perfetto
allora se riusciste a fare le cose
normali normali calmi
cap nola portanova cosa fa quello che sa
fare stretching zio sono dei casi persi
cosa volete che faccia tanto c'è anche
il punteggio stanno vincendo i blu com
immaginatevi sta roba colo colo servito
ragazzi uscite scemi non lo giocherò
michael obus
ok ragazzi in tutto questo voglio
provare la madonna devi stare calmo zio
non ho capito come funziona la mano
allora io la metto giù mi fate dei
comandi della mano per cortesia grazie
ci sono qua mouse move mouse scroll come
la giro così perfetto è come john mica
sono un po più incasinato addirittura ok
non so quanto possa funzionare ma ci
prova che la giornata è una merda per
voi lo vede proviamo madonna da golf
golf 6 a 9 da che eravamo 6 a 0 a 6 a 9
com'è possibile allora farmi prendere la
palla sede da palla la voglio io e mia
al sogno che diggle gioco
dovete togliervi spazio pure le famiglie
fa mi prende stop alla maledetta giu
perfetto chiudi no la fa la palla la
palla prendo io fermi fuck you page nodo
dove cazzo uscito questo presa no no
devi stare fermo da due scissa gente
stai fermo o toglietevi madonna dio ti
ringrazio mi fate dire le regole ma
andate a cagare fatemi dire le regole
scusa di niente non ascolta non è un
inglese non mi mangio che la domanda te
voglio state a casa ragazzi state a casa
avete fermi bum bam 12 morti arriva
quello tutto solo incredibile davanti
alla porta bravo bravo perfetto è così
che si gioca a calcio ai ragazzi ho solo
provato ha giocato sopra dove cazzo sono
finito non lo so nell'oltretomba cioè
quel gioco di calcio bruttissimo che in
confronto è veramente fifa a livello di
giocabilità la cosa più penosa io che ha
mai giocato però c'è il suo fascino un
ragazzo io devo ammetterlo quindi
ragazzo la discarica film sia piaciuto e
che è stato alquanto non senso però non
che i miei video di solito siano
intelligenti per evidenziare 100 ragazzi
con cromie episodio caso le stesse
misure sono al momento mi piace anche a
pacini facebook e co meglio tutta la
descrizione senza il city sky ci
invidiavano così un video
i ragazzi vi giuro che imparerò a
giocare sto gioco e fare un altro
episodio ve lo giuro
però per adesso no beh ragazzi